We know that Thanos's Infinity Gauntlet is
going to be making a return in Avengers: Endgame.
The only question is just what's going to
happen with it.
Will one of the heroes manage to take the
Infinity Gauntlet and use its incredible power
for themselves?
Here's why these superheroes might wear the
Infinity Gauntlet in Endgame.
If there's one character you actually want
to see controlling the Infinity Stones and
the omnipotent power that goes along with
them, it's Steve Rogers, the guy who always
does the right thing, no matter what.
"We may not be perfect, but the safest hands
are still our own."
If he got his hands on the Gauntlet, then
it's easy to see how all of that death and
destruction at the end of Infinity War could
be corrected, he'd set things right again
even if there was a huge cost to doing so,
which there almost certainly would be.
When Thanos uses the Infinity Gauntlet at
the end of Infinity War, we see that the gauntlet
itself is burnt out and damaged, nearly shattered
by the forces that it channeled.
That's no mean feat considering that it was
crafted by the same dwarves who crafted Mjolnir,
which took a literal goddess of death to break.
Thanos survived the Gauntlet's power surge,
but he's also an incredibly powerful Titan.
Captain America can run faster than a luxury
vehicle, leap off rooftops, and bicep curl
a helicopter, and he's the moral fiber that
holds the Avengers together.
"S—- … Language!"
His indomitable will would no doubt give him
the ability to use the Gauntlet, but surviving
it is a different question.
The backlash in controlling those forces and
unwinding time to make things right would
give him the perfect opportunity for the heroic
sacrifice that would bring the character to
the end that Chris Evans and the Russo brothers
have been hinting at.
Tony Stark might not seem like the prime candidate
to wear the Gauntlet, but if you think about
it, he fits, wait for it, like a glove.
After all, for all its mystical sci-fi trappings,
the Gauntlet is just another piece of technology,
and technology is Iron Man's specialty.
"When did you become an expert in thermonuclear
astrophysics?
… Last night."
All this happened in the comic books already.
He's actually the first human in the Marvel
Universe to wield the Gauntlet, a relatively
recent event that happened in the pages of
Avengers in 2011.
One of the most interesting things about that
is what Tony does with it: he creates an illusion
of the Gauntlet being destroyed, but then
secretly hands off the Stones to the people
he trusts most.
Of course, all that stuff about heroic sacrifice
still applies to Tony, and this may give us
a fond farewell to Robert Downey Jr., allowing
Jim Rhodes to step into the armor as the new
Iron Man.
"Merry Christmas, buddy."
The most likely character to wear the Infinity
Gauntlet in Endgame might also be the most
surprising, at least for MCU fans who haven't
checked out the source material.
Thanos daughter Nebula played a critical role to the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
in the comics, and given what happened to
Gamora in Infinity War, she has the personal
motivation too.
In the original Infinity Gauntlet storyline,
Thanos' murder of half the universe isn't
his climactic goal, it's his opening move.
When the surviving heroes head out to the
edge of the universe, Thanos brutally destroys
them one by one.
All the while, Nebula is there watching, trapped
in a desiccated corpse and kept on the edge
of life and death just to amuse Thanos.
There is, however, enough consciousness left
in her that she's able to eventually steal
the gauntlet when Thanos abandons his body,
and shifts the timeline back by 24 hours,
before Thanos snapped his fingers and killed
off the heroes.
If the movies go a similar way, that could
add a very personal element to the struggle
against Thanos.
In the movies, Nebula has been tortured her
entire life, her body replaced piece by piece
with cybernetics as punishment for her "failures,"
leaving her in the disassembled state that
we see in Infinity War.
She's already vowed to hunt him down and return
the favor.
"...yeah."
Not only that, but Gamora, the "sister" who
tried to protect her, was murdered by Thanos.
If Gamora stays dead, Nebula's vengeance on
Thanos would be very satisfying, and could
even set her up to join the Guardians, bonding
with Star-Lord over the loss of Gamora.
"Well, well … You should have killed me
… It would have been a waste of parts."
Bruce Banner might just be the most compelling
choice to get control of the Infinity Gauntlet
in Endgame.
Since Thor: Ragnarok, we've seen the Hulk
at war with his alter ego, and in Infinity
War, that was compounded when the greener
side of Banner's personality refused to come
out and fight, even when the world was at
stake.
"Dude you're embarrassing me in front of the wizard."
If Banner does take control of the Gauntlet,
he might use it to finally find the harmony
between the warring factions of his psyche
that he's been looking for since he was created.
That could give us another element of the
comics: a unified version of the Hulk who
has the gamma-powered body of the Green Goliath,
and the brilliant mind of Bruce Banner.
We could get quite a bit out of the idea of
Banner controlling the Infinity Gauntlet,
including a chance for Mark Ruffalo to do
some Hulk acting that wasn't limited to monosyllabes
and smashing.
"I Smash you"
"yeah yeah, sure."
Baby arms.
what?
"baby!"
The God of Thunder armed with both the unstoppable
Stormbreaker and the Infinity Gauntlet is
pretty much the definition of "overpowered."
We'll admit that this seems like a pretty
unlikely scenario, but believe it or not,
something similar happened in the comics.
Way back in 2000's Thor #25, the God of Thunder
took on Thanos in one of the most brutal fights
to hit the comics page.
While Thanos was winning at first, Thor geared
up with a whole new set of mystical artifacts
enchanted by Odin, and wound up beating the
purple out of the Mad Titan until he was face-down
in the Asgardian dirt.
Unlikely, yes, but also pretty rad.
Loki, in case you forgot, is dead.
He was killed in the opening scenes of Infinity
War, murdered by Thanos after trying to save
the brother he spent so much of his time luring
into hilarious stabbings.
"He transformed himself into a snake and he
knows that I love snakes so I went to pick
up the snake to admire it and he transformed
back into himself and went “blah!
It’s me!” and he stabbed me."
That said, death has never exactly stopped
Loki before, so why would it be a problem
now?
Coming back from the dead is what the dude
does, and a last-second revival and a theft
of the Infinity Gauntlet might just tip the
scales in Endgame.
You’re not going to believe this one, but
it kinda happened before in the comics…
kinda.
In the original Infinity Gauntlet comic, Thanos
is paired up with Mephisto, a demon who eventually
betrays him.
The thing is, Mephisto doesn't currently exist
in the MCU.
Instead, the role of a lackey who eventually
betrays Thanos has actually fallen to Loki.
Plus, we already know that there's a Loki
TV show in development, with Tom Hiddleston
attached to star.
Unless it's a prequel, he's definitely coming
back in some form or another.
If he gains control of the Infinity Gauntlet
and somehow manages to resist the corrupting
influence of absolute power, that could complete
the shift in his character from unrepentant
villain to devious antihero, exactly what
he needs to be if he's going to be a protagonist
from here on out.
The trailer for Endgame is relentlessly depressing,
full of stuff like Tony Stark recording his
final message to Pepper, Steve Rogers shedding
tears over the fate of his friends, and Clint
Barton looking haunted in the rain.
That is, until the very end, when Ant-Man
shows up and suddenly things are as goofy
as they've ever been.
"Can you buzz me in?"
Scott Lang getting his hands on the Infinity
Gauntlet would be pretty shocking, but it's
not entirely unlikely.
The entire Marvel Universe is about the little
guy managing to triumph over impossible odds.
In both a figurative and literal sense, there's
no littler guy than Ant-Man.
It's also his chance to actually save the
world.
One of the fun things about the Ant-Man films
is that they have smaller stakes than the
rest of the MCU.
Getting him involved in something this big
would be weird and wild enough to be really
fun.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.